SO WHY DID IGNATIUS RUN WITH IT
AND WHERE IS HIS APOLOGY FOR
STARTING THIS MESS QUEST MIGHT
TURN TO ME NOW IS CONGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN, RANKING MEMBER OF
THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, SINCE THE MEDIA ARE
NOT GOING TO SEARCH FOR NEW
LEADS, YOU KNOW, IT’S LED TO
FOLKS LIKE YOU.
ONE FACT MISSING THUS FAR IS
WHAT DID THE ACTUAL REQUEST FOR
UNMASKING SAY?
BECAUSE UNMASKING IS NOT
ILLEGAL.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DO THAT.
BUT WHAT IS A REQUEST FOR
UNMASKING ACTUALLY SAVED BY ALL
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO FILE THEM
AGAINST FLYNN?
>> WHAT WAS THEIR REASON AND WHY
SO MANY PEOPLE, AND WHY ALL OF
THIS INTERESTING TIME CUSTOMER
COMMITTEE WITH CHEERLEADERS FOR
THIS ENTIRE EFFORT AND THEIR
CHEERLEADING TOOK PLACE AT
INTERESTING TIMES AS WELL.
THINK ABOUT JANUARY OF 2017
DURING THIS TRANSITION.
ON THE FOURTH OF JANUARY YOU GOT
PETER STRZOK TELLING AGENTS,
DON’T DROP THE CASE AGAINST
FLYNN, KEEP IT UP, COMEY TOLD ME
TO KEEP PURSUING FLYNN.
THE NEXT DAY, HE MEETS WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA IN THE
OVAL OFFICE AND TALKS ABOUT MIKE
FLYNN.
JANUARY 6TH, COMEY GOES UP AND
BRIEFED HIM ON THE DOSSIER THAT
HE ALREADY KNOWS IS FALSE,
MISLEADING AND PAID FOR BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THEN THAT
LEAKS.
THE FACT THAT HE HAD THAT
CONVERSATION, THEN HE POINTED
OUT JANUARY 12, DAVID IGNATIUS’
STORY LAKES AND WHAT DID THEY DO
ON THE 24TH OF JANUARY?
JIM COMEY SENDS TWO AGENTS,
SNEAKS THEM INTO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO SET UP MICHAEL FLYNN.
THAT IGNATIUS STORY HELP ALL
THAT PLAY OUT BUT THEY ARE
CHEERLEADERS NOT JUST IN A
GENERAL SENSE FOR THE DEMOCRATS
BUT THEY ARE CHEERLEADERS AT
INTERESTING TIMES IN THE
SEQUENCE OF EVENTS.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS WE
NEED TO GET ANSWERS TO.
>> Laura: AS SOMEONE SAID
EARLIER TODAY, I CAN’T REMEMBER
WHAT I WAS WATCHING BUT IT WAS
LIKE THE JOURNALIST BECOMES
PARTICIPANTS IN THE ONGOING SAGA
TO TRY TO KNEECAP TRUMP OR TAKE
OUT ONE OF HIS TOP PEOPLE TO
THEN KNEECAP TRUMP.
SO THEY BECOME PARTICIPANTS,
RATHER THAN CURIOUS, AGGRESSIVE
JOURNALISTS.
MAYBE THERE IS A DEEPER STORY
HERE.
WHAT’S YOUR MOTIVATION AND THEY
CAME TO ME?
INSTEAD JUST REPEATING IT,
RUNNING WITH IT.
BEING A LIBERAL REPORTER MEANS
NEVER HAVING TO SAY YOU’RE SORRY
SORRY.
>> AND THEY SHOULD HAVE TO SAY
THAT BECAUSE REMEMBER WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
THEY SPOT ON OUR CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS NOT TRUE, NO COLLUSION
BETWEEN ANYTHING OUR CAMPAIGN
DID, ANYTHING I DID AND RUSSIA.
HE SAID THOSE THINGS AND OF
COURSE HE SAID THIS WHOLE THING
WAS A WITCH HUNT.
NOW AFTER ALL THESE FACTS COME
OUT WE SEE EXACTLY THAT.
EACH OF THOSE THREE STATEMENTS
BY THE PRESIDENT HAS PROVEN TO
BE TRUE AND YET THEY JUST KEEP
ON GOING WITH THEIR NARRATIVE
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO DETERMINED
TO GO AFTER THIS PRESIDENT.
THIS IS A SIMPLE PRINCIPLE HERE.
WHEN YOU DRAIN THE SWAMP THE
SWAMP FIGHTS BACK, EVEN WHEN
THEY KNOW THEY ARE WRONG AND
EVEN WHEN IT’S PROVEN THEY ARE
WRONG THEY KEEP FIGHTING BACK.
>> Laura: LAST NIGHT DURING A
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" EXCLUSIVE,
YOU SENT A LETTER TO POMPEO
ABOUT THIS.
TELL US VERY QUICKLY, ABOUT 30
SECONDS.
>> WHAT SHE SAID IN THE
DEPOSITION AND THE IMPEACHMENT
HEREHEARING IS DIFFERENT THAN WH
HE SAID.
I GIVE THEM A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF CREDIT BECAUSE HE PUSHED HER
AND GOT HER TO SAY IT WAS JUST A
BRIEFING I WAS GETTING READY FOR
MY CONFIRMATION BUT IT TURNS
OUT, SHE TALKED ABOUT BURISMA
AND HUNTER BIDEN A LOT MORE THAN
SHE INDICATED.
WE WANT TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS
UNREDACTED SO WE CAN GET A
BETTER AND CLOSER LOOK ABOUT
WHAT REALLY TOOK PLACE HERE.
>> Laura: WE’RE TALKING ABOUT
THE LINE IS ASIAN OF
WHISTLE-BLOWERS AND PEOPLE
RELATED TO WHISTLE-BLOWERS